oh I don't mind I just feel like I could
hit okay you see the key any other
advice are you left or right-handed
right right so you know right leg back
so you really get the whole it goes away
you go you go boom it goes back up okay
I honestly mine was so bad so let's see
what Rachel gets and then I'll decide if
I'm going to do it leg forwards yeah
yeah you in range though are you in
range I don't know let's should I find
out is that come forward a bit I can't
afford a bit because you want to
remember your aim is to punch through
the bag through so I want to go like
that yes I like that
[Applause]
yeah but Joseph Parker who's a tidy
champion area is there he has one of the
other belts can I guess that looks like
it ought to be quite an easy fine
[Applause]
[Laughter]
world-class athlete but he doesn't look
like one does he I mean you can't
underestimate you know the thing is with
with boxing I think you know the things
that you like you can make up for in
power in the heavyweight division yeah
and there's not like there's not one
heavyweight that hasn't gone without
getting dropped in their whole career
and that's what I realized is that um a
lot of Fighters have lost their titles
fruit underestimate and other athletes
like for instance Lennox Lewis when he
was he was filming I think Ocean's
eleven yeah and he lost his title cuz he
wasn't focused and no no heavyweight
champion is one heavyweight champion of
the world they're all two-time
heavyweight champion three-time because
of the last thing they lose is the power
in their punch yeah so I can't even
though he looks like the pie eater so
I'm gonna be I'm focus I'm in training
camp now you know he's secret open
armpit hair so he's got cats
okay what do I need to 182 to be 180
[Applause]
whatever you don't care than you do yeah
come and just have a staredown with it
is whom laughs first okay
[Applause]
zone postbox got a picture of that this
is where is this this is in Watford in
half a lovely and how do we know
it's yours
I don't have to my names on it I don't
know but you know what you I know that's
[Laughter]
we're very proud of you he's only two
belts away from total world domination
but you are actively looking for a cool
boxing name because I haven't got one No
so it's Anthony AJ Joshua right now you
can say that yeah Anthony AJ yeah she
was drunk that's your name that's my but
have you tried any cool names
honestly big Josh they call my dad big
Josh something big Josh I don't know I
don't know mailbox Josh
[Applause]
yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
594 to beat here we go here we go
but the thing is boxing does have a
really diverse group of fans so you're
wasting I think you were in Wembley
Stadium waiting to go on and you got
face time to face found you
it was interesting cars getting physio
and stuff just getting the final bits
and bobs done and I've listened to
hip-hop the majority of my life and dr.
Dre you know we work with Beats By Dre
and all that stuff and it's not someone
that you expect to call you you already
expect to work with the team who kind of
help push your brand and stuff and then
does that come to the kitchen and
someone's on the phone Anita speech whoo
so imagine I'm like goodness sake these
like don't leave me alone man
I'm trying to do my physio and I walk in
I'm eating my sandwich and then dr.
Dre's on the phone so it's like I don't
know who you look up to or who your
music icons are but dr. Dre was one of
mine and it was unbelievable to have him
on the FaceTime talking with me
What did he say just like good luck very
well wish you a lot of luck with the
fire now that just along the lines of
like cause of the type of fight it was
coach ko he reigned for ten years and
he's well known yeah I'm up on cars up
and come in I was trying to get his
belts so he had heard about the fight
and down though is that yeah yeah in the
professional ranks right and yeah coach
go you know he threw a punch and it
whizzed past me and I slipped actually
so I didn't actually go down I see it
oh yeah are you so doing this thing you
posted this video and it's a training
technical thing before so is this a
genuine training just made from a normal
cap elastics drink in the tennis ball
boxes like that sweat this is oh yeah
it's the exciting game that everybody
like yes
[Applause]
that is reality we live in because that
was about the 1000 that I had done that
looked good I'm not good at this you're
already good in the video can we see the
video again does this means you will be
able to defeat any tennis ball it is
much harder than it looks I try it I'm
good no so I try this is often because
it does that does not look hard
does it mmm that does not look hard no
let's try to see so do you throw it up
and hit it or what is it however you
feel comfortable there's no right or
wrong technique but just keep it away
from your face
[Applause]
oh no I'm
I'm still going okay I tell you what was
yours eight eight P was three thousand
six and two wasn't what six seven two
six three two so if you don't beat that
tightly okay okay here we go here we go
this technique adieu the world champion
[Applause]
[Music]
you